welcome to this point of a corner so
you're seen seen elsewhere review - it's
it's essentially that it's it's and we
feared it out pretty early that you know
it's a kid's imagination yeah I'm here
making this all up only I didn't figure
that party didn't necessarily figure out
I didn't know what cuz it was kind of
open-ended I didn't know where they were
going all I knew is that the Legos
existed in the real world because of the
relics and I started to put together
that this is either a basement a garage
a child's playroom is something but
there is some in the hand there and then
like somebody's controlling it the
degree to who is controlling it if there
was still things that were like my
initial thought was like maybe it was
gonna be a garage that the child had
some juego display and he just hasn't
come back and played with in a long time
so it's like Toy Story the way goes in
run amuck everything I don't know so so
so the reason this works out really well
is because because it's a kid playing
with all this he knows all the cliches
he's representing all the cliches he's
seen in the imagery or he's yet with
what he has around him the immaturity of
all the Lego characters makes total
sense in the screw enos of the story
makes sense because it's a child making
it up and what but the heart part of it
is that there's a story going on where
the father who's who is played by Will
Ferrell was also the villain the little
lego villain a he's like mr. business or
something he wants to freeze everything
in place and he's gonna use this device
that's pretty much Krazy Glue and in
reality that's what the father wants to
do the father's built this you know
utopia city of Legos I really got very
organized obviously got OCD yeah a huge
collector really obsessed and the kid
comes like he keeps playing with it
keeps telling him no so things gonna
glue everybody in place so that the kid
can't play with them a more he won't
ruin his masterpiece and that's what's
going in the world he doesn't want I
don't even
I think it was that I think he had glued
stuff to begin with just because he
always wanted no no no no he was
beginning to you saw it's like you know
now we're gonna change the see here we
go and he's starting to glue everything
and then in the fictional world
everyone's getting glued to and what
comes around is the the boy and his
father connecting you know finding out
that there is kind of it in between and
the father sees the creativity that the
boy does with his imagination combining
different elements and stuff and he in
him the boy really bond and really come
together it's really really nice uh and
then there's a really clever could
beauty of it is it's true that was my
childhood that was always the question I
had it's like okay I've got this new
thing do I follow the instructions or do
I build something by myself yeah and the
father was finding the instructions yeah
we and when I was a kid like we had an
airport set and dad did superglue it
because he didn't want to well we were
so young that yeah you would have been
like four oh yeah you would have been in
three or four I would have been like
five or six or something but you know I
didn't have a concept how to put him as
a giant set it was like some airports
that this is the knitter early eighties
and I don't know how to put the whole
thing together so when so he built it he
was done he's super good with the whole
thing so it would never get wrecked and
he wouldn't have to build it again the
memories coming back and Janet izing me
about those movies pretty you don't know
but I mean that was always true and like
so there's a real true life thing is
like do you follow any instruction book
do you make up your own thing Mo's like
if you I collect toys and then never
open yeah I knew they have them just to
have them so it really rang true to me
for my childhood because I'm like yeah I
did the exact same thing it's like
sometimes I'm like no I want everything
in this place I'm not perfect I'm just
like I always do whatever so so there is
only one problem I have with this entire
movie um it's the only thing that
bothered the killing spree ending I mean
I haven't seen that coming everybody
dies and Isaac um um everybody does
oh it's okay so the character the Emma
character goes through the little Lego
piece goes through this portal he's on
the other end he figures out he's a toy
and he sees what's going on with the boy
and the father and stuff like that
and the father sets him down and the
piece wants him to help the father out
and stuff so he doesn't superglue
everything and he actually starts to
move and he moves around it's not much I
mean but it's enough just to bring him
down to this one piece you know that
gets him to look at it and realize what
he's missing and stuff I don't like the
fact that the piece moved I really would
have liked it if everything was just in
the kids mind because okay even the
magic of Legos see that that's the thing
so you mean all this time like I haven't
been talking to you so okay so I really
would have liked it better if instead of
it moving that it wasn't like the power
magic and just the Lego actually had a
personality like that can move around
and consciousness and stuff that it's
the imagination of the boy and the
creativity that won everything over that
it's so powerful and so strong that that
is sort of what changed worlds here
without literally having something come
to life I guess there sort of goes
Disney ish but I think it just went then
more powerful if it really was just all
in his mind the whole time personally so
not one Lego asked you to build or
create or imagine or kill maybe one okay
now I feel better but I swum kind of
agree with you this is a look
I think this seemed bothered me just
because Will Ferrell is like you got
this Lego going like if you want ice
it's okay but then it keeps going it's
like okay he's got the other half I'm
like yeah I mean how do you miss that I
would have been like what the well
he sees something others anytime this
yeah I would have been calling an
exorcist a bad boy ever like what this
is the house is haunted um I like that
it's not much but it's still giving in
to the idea
I really like the idea of the ending of
them coming together in the father
realizing no I should let you play with
these in the imagination we can play
together I thought the way it was
executed was a little hallmark movie of
the week you know what he does like it
was a little sad yeah the way the hug
was a little in there
it didn't feel natural surf felt like
this I guess some people get say well
that's there's supposed to be kind of
uncomfortable
I don't know that this was a little odd
it felt it just I don't know it felt
like something I would have seen on the
Family Channel it was a little too sappy
for me it directed the movie no no I did
again the grasping at straws here but
like if I'm thinking of the very few
things that I was coming you know I was
like I probably wouldn't preferred if it
was a little less sappy in the execution
but that again so I mean you got through
this ending fine but you're the one who
wails on Toy Story three for being sappy
at the end I still like Toby story three
just as sappy if no no no because that
moment was only let you in this movie is
only like you know not even a half a
minute or so five minutes of this but
they're ramping up three films is the
first movie if at the end of the third
okay he doesn't want a two-minute okay
nope if you can work where because if
you had the little Lego wave and welfare
like oh like that it would have been
funny in this one Toy Story 3 it's just
weird and awkward and uncomfortable and
stupid you know what uh send all of your
pics are related to hate mail it's sappy
I should talk like that I mean not that
what I'm saying I stand by what I'm
saying you're a monster
so uh but because it was shortened it
bothered me to a bit but I mean it's
it's short and the whole film was mostly
really fine with Toy Story 3 was going
to like really heavy drama you know I
think by this start starting
light-hearted throughout the whole thing
even during the heavier moments uh it
comes across as more effective which is
why I think you're right when he does
the hug it does feel that's the point
where goes a little too dramatic and
maybe a little too like you said to
Hallmark II when they take it too
serious you know whatever gets you to
sleep at night oh and the finale finale
with the duplo set though he's like well
I hope this means that you know that
your little sister playing that oh yeah
oh wow I want to see I want a sequel and
I wanted to be like the duplo Wars like
well what's so clever there's a scene
again we could talk about before but
where they're talking about all these
different worlds and they show the
what's all the duplo diplo duplication
of the duplo toys it's like yeah but
we'll talk about those Oh
here we have the blah blah blah and your
count why did they skip that so fast I
was worried you realize that - what his
little sister plays with and you know
it's just I know why that what the real
Legos I want the in my weight my little
sister we tries to play with me and
stuff like that so Morgan Freeman plays
a wizard a ghost and a talking cat
sister how could this not be the
greatest movie ever made
it's it's pretty awesome I'm trying to
think anything else - about the ending
that like need to bring up for a wrap-up
I mean yeah it is what makes what
separates this from just a fun you know
creative stupid movie - like love this
is like really smart and really clever
and the voice acting - was not obnoxious
no funny thing is like you know Morgan
Freeman's so sticks out like a sore
thumb and he's in everything now they
have fun with it they had fun with it
and honestly it took me about a minute
before was like oh is that Morgan
Freeman
like I just he sticks out pretty clear
it was not like some of the other roles
maybe it's because the style of comedy
he's doing is different from his like
narrator voice but yeah every single
person in the cameos were great - they
they Anthony Daniels is Threepio and
though I'm a lady I there's an Lord not
Harrison Ford person oh they probably
made prophet came up through he's like
hey we would like you to be in a lego
movie get off my lawn well I'd be in a
fridge I'll only do it if I'm in a
fridge I don't do kids movies Crystal
Skull was the last one so um yeah
yeah good good flick anything else the
wrap-up fun no I just everything is
awesome everything is awesome go see it